ok certains de mes meilleurs travaux je pense qu'est
-ce que vous pensez que c'est bon mais que
diriez-vous d'ajouter plus de dinosaures oh puis-je
vraiment ajouter plus de dinosaures c'est que
vous n'êtes pas un stagiaire oui je suis
oh allez temps nous devons télécharger cette bande-annonce
ouais j'ai ce gars les gars l'ont fait
tout à coup juste devenir honnête ici
votre téléphone ouais merci
vous auriez pu utiliser la lampe de poche
maintenant après vous les gars
vous allez sortir d'ici
je dois y aller tu dois y aller tu dois y aller
allons  allez sur trois trois deux
c'est le système UNIX Je sais qu'à un
moment donné tu vas le remettre dans
mon téléphone, puis-je avoir Instagram Zack
obtenir cette bande-annonce sur une disquette
oh mon dieu attends donc c'est un chat
qui a fait le dinosaure  son et
déchiré le moniteur quelque chose semble gentil
de ta part